- Welcome, everyone.
Today, we have the pleasure of
having Professor Andrés Moya
from the economics department
at Universidad de Los Andes,
who is visiting fellow at
the David Rockefeller Center
for Latin American Studies
at Harvard University.
Professor Moya will be talking today
about promoting mental health
and early childhood
development in Columbia.
Professor Moya research
focuses on the economic,
psychological, and behavioral consequences
of violence and force
displacement in Colombia.
In particular, Professor
Moya has analyzed the effect
of violence and psychological
trauma on economic behavior,
human capital accumulation,
and performance in the labor market.
So Professor Moya, the
floor is yours, thanks.
- So thank you so much
for the great opportunity to present here.
I'm gonna be presenting the
impact evaluation results
of this program called Semillas de Apego,
which roughly translates
as seeds for attachment.
And it's a project that
it's a joint endeavor
between psychologists at the
University of California,
San Francisco and economists
at the University of Los
Angeles where I'm based.
And the whole idea of this project is
to promote the maternal mental health
and early childhood development
in conflict affected communities.
So I'm gonna be presenting
the results for the RCT
that we implemented in Columbia.
And maybe just to start with
a little bit of the motivation
for this talk,
right now, and this is probably something
that people here know very well.
Right now, over 2
billion people are living
in conflict-affected settings.
Among these populations,
children have been
disproportionately effected.
450 million children globally,
around 20% of children in the world
live and are born in these settings.
And we have also witnessed
the increase in displacement,
both refugee flows internal displacement
in the past decades.
Right now, by the end of 2021,
we had 82 million displaced persons,
including 35 million children.
And of course,
right now we're actually
witnessing very sadly
the increase in displacement
and refugee flows
in the Ukraine.
What we know is that
the exposure to conflict
and displacement can have
very long lasting consequences
across different dimensions.
It can take a toll in mental health.
It can actually affect product poverty.
It can thrust to populations into
both economic, social and
technological poverty traps.
And we know from research
that it can hinder
and affect early child development
and that by doing so,
it can affect the last trajectories
of many of these children.
So of course, when we
think about the magnitude
of this problem and the magnitude
of the conflicts across the
globe there's a main question
in terms of how can we protect children,
and how can we prevent
the intergenerational
transmission of trauma and poverty
in these conflict affected settings?
So this is the broad motivation
that we're gonna be working.
And we know at least when
we dig into the literature
about the childhood development,
we know that children
need nurturing stimulation
relationship with an adult
for proper early childhood development.
We know that these type of relationships
are actually important for children
to be able to process
the stress that arises
in maybe everyday settings.
So these nurturing and
and caring relationships
can actually buffer the
psychological effects of stress.
And these are effects that
occur at both a neuronal
and biological levels, so
not only a behavioral effect.
And based on this,
we also know that the toxic stress
emerges when children are exposed
to severe and systematic adversities,
and when the adults are not available
to provide these nurturing relationships.
So what happens with toxic stress
is that the biological
stress response systems
of the children are being
toxically activated.
Think children that has been
experimenting displacement,
poverty, exclusion,
it's being bombarded by
different adversities
that are gonna trigger
this biological stress response system.
And when the child doesn't
receive that proper nurturing
and caring relationship by the parent,
this stress response is
gonna be constantly activated
and pretty much in an overload.
And this is gonna have
very negative effects
on child's brain architecture,
the number of connections of the neurons,
the strength of the neuronal connections.
And it's also gonna affect
physical and mental health,
and it's gonna have very
life-altering effects, right?
And so the key question here is,
how to promote these
nurturing relationships
in context of conflict
and forced displacement?
And when we think about our
project, we take a step back
and we think about the binding constraint.
So the binding constraint here
is the capacity of caregivers
to build these nurturing relationships.
And we consider that these
capacities are not exogenous.
They're actually endogenous
to the context of conflict.
Conflict and displacement
actually have negative
consequences on caregivers mental health.
Parents who are struggling
with trying to understand displacement,
trying to cope with the shock of conflict
are actually gonna have less
emotional resources available
to be able to understand what's happening
at the same time to connect
with their children.
In Colombia, we know for instance,
that the incidence of at
risk symptoms of anxiety
and depression are three
to four times greater
in conflict affected regions
than in other regions
not affected by conflict.
And we know that the severity
of these psychological problems
are gonna drain the emotional
resources of caregivers.
And this is gonna hinder their capacity
to be emotionally available
for children, right?
So again, children are
being affected by the stress
that characterizes these
conflict affected settings,
these settings of conflict
and forced displacement,
but at the time their caregivers
are also being affected.
And this is gonna drain their capacity
to better connect in a nurturing
and caring relationships
with their children.
And so this creates this
concern for the toxic stress
and the life consequences
that it's gonna have with the children.
So what we do, and this is
the purpose of this talk,
is we develop this program
called Semillas de Apego,
again, it roughly translates
as seeds for attachment.
And it's a community-based
psychological model
for caregivers of young children
who have also been affected
by conflict and displacement.
And in developing the
program we take a step back
and we again, recognize
this binding constraint
and the capacity of caregivers
to provide these nurturing
and care relationships is not exogenous,
it's being affected at the same time
by conflict and dis displacement.
So we recognize that if we
want to protect children,
and if we want to enhance these nurturing,
caring relationships,
we need to take a step back and think
about the emotional
resources of the caregivers.
And we need to think
about the maternal mental health in gen.
So the objective of our program is
to promote maternal mental
health as an outcome itself,
a development outcome that's
very important by itself,
but also it's gonna be important
because it's a vehicle for us
to promote healthy
child-parent relationships,
and then to protect early child life.
We implemented this program in
a setting of active conflict,
we're gonna be working,
and I'm gonna tell you a
little bit more later on,
we're gonna be working in
a municipality in Colombia
that has been chronically
affected by conflict.
82% of the participants
are victims of violence.
54% are actually internally
displaced persons.
We observed high levels
of maternal mental health at baseline.
And we also observed that (voice distorts)
was happening at the same time
as we were implementing the program.
So this creates challenges
for implementing
as we're evaluating these programs.
And despite these challenges,
what we see is in a nutshell,
very positive results
at an eight month follow up,
and the four core dimensions
that we intend to improve.
So we see positive effects of
point 15 standard deviations
in an index of mental health,
0.23 standard deviations
in an index of child-parent relationships.
And we see effects of point 17
and point 21 standard deviations
on early child mental health
and early child development respectively.
So that's pretty much the
summary of what we did.
And me just highlight a
couple of contributions
from our study.
One, and as I've been trying to reinforce
throughout this introduction,
our program actually addresses
maternal mental health explicitly.
And this is a totally different approach
from that of other successful
parenting interventions
that have been implemented
in non-conflict settings.
So we know about the very positive results
of the Jamaica Home Visit Intervention,
We know about the different interventions
and the evidence from the research program
that actually builds up
on the Jamaica program.
This has been implemented
in different countries
in the region, it has also
been implemented in Colombia,
both in rural and urban areas.
They're very positive results.
We also know that these interventions,
they're more in type
of play-based learning
are being currently adapted
to respond to Syrian refugee crisis,
along with the Ahlan Simsim program.
But again, these programs
and these interventions
tackle a different constraint.
So if we take a step back,
maybe we can think
that they tackle informational constraints
on why and how to promote responsive care
and stimulating environments.
We have these both group based
in home visiting programs
where a facilitator sits
down with the family
to start playing with the children
and encourage the family
to play with the children.
So this is very important
and it addresses an important constraint.
But again, this is a different constraint
than the one that we're trying to address.
We take a step back and
we consider explicitly
the role of maternal mental health
and being able to promote
this responsive care
and stimulating play.
And this is actually important.
There's actually few impact evaluations
of early childhood in progress
that are addressing deficits
in maternal mental health.
There's a recent paper that
was published last year
in science,
a review paper of 478 early
child development evaluations.
And what they find is
that only 12% actually measure
maternal mental health.
And when they do this,
it's often to try to identify
dimensions for heterogeneity.
So whether parents with better
or worse maternal mental
health are actually
having better or worse effects
from the interventions.
But what I think this highlights is
that most of these programs
are actually not considering
the role of maternal mental health
in improving these outcomes.
The second contribution is that
we're conducting this program
and experimental evaluation
in a setting of active conflict.
By 2018, there were only five evaluations
being implemented at these
conflict affected settings,
mostly in post conflict settings,
mostly in refugee camps.
But here we're actually
implementing the program
in a setting where conflict is much alive,
where there were struggles
by different groups
to control the Coca
drug trade in Colombia.
And because of this civilians
were severely victimized
at the same time as we were
implementing the program.
So these are caregivers that
are affected by displacement,
by on-going conflict.
And this creates a lot of
challenges to implement
and evaluate these programs.
And this is actually going to map
in the experimental design
that we're gonna follow
and that I'm gonna talk
about a little bit later.
And perhaps the third contribution is
that we implement the program
in a community-based model.
The program is delivered
by community members
who had no prior experience.
So we're gonna train
them and supervise them.
And this allows us to
overcome the deficits
in local capacities
and in professional mental health services
that are characteristics of countries
in the global south in general,
and more so in conflict-effected settings.
So these three contributions,
taking maternal mental health explicitly
in the designing of the program,
implementing the program in
context of active conflict,
and doing so through a
community-based model
are gonna be the main
contributions that we think
actually allow us to
observe the positive effects
that we were seeing before.
So that being said,
let me skip into the
description of the (indistinct).
Okay, well, the program, we
designed the curriculum in 2014,
we tested a pilot in Bogotá,
an implementation pilot in Bogotá in 2015,
And then we started running
the impact evaluation in 2018.
So where does the program comes from?
It's inspired by the
work of our colleagues,
Alicia Lieberman and Vilma Reyes at UCSF.
Alicia had been working for
more than two decades now
on what's called the
Child-Parent Psychotherapy.
This is a clinical intervention.
It lasts 37 sessions per year
between the child-parent diet
and the trained
psychologist in the clinic.
Its effectiveness has been
done by five clinical trials
with mostly Latino and
Afro-American communities.
And then when they realized
a little bit of the
obstacles of scaling this up,
they brought this out to the community.
And that's the building
bridges interventions
that was led by (indistinct) 2011.
So these are at least the CPP and spirit.
It's a therapeutic session
to enhance parents
capacity to provide safety
and developmentally
appropriate caregiving.
It's been implemented
in 37 States in the US,
also in Palestine and Israel.
And also I think in more
of these the countries.
(voice distorts)
You're good?
- [Woman] The camera not focused on you.
- [Moya] So one second while
we fix the camera, sorry.
Ah, but if I stand here.
- [Woman] Yes.
- [Man] If you stand
up, that would be great.
- [Moya] Here?
- [Woman] Yes.
- [Man] Can you see him now?
(voice distorts)
- [Moya] I apologize for interrupting-
- No.
- [Moya] Thank you so much.
- [Man] You're welcome.
- [Moya] Okay, and so again,
we contacted the team at UCSF in 2014,
they had this track
record of intervention.
And so we adapted the program
to the local conflicts in Columbia.
So what we were trying
to understand, well,
how do we adapt it to a conflict
that's ongoing conflict?
It's different to the needs
and the characteristic
of Latino communities
that migrated to the US, to California,
and from which the original
program actually emerged.
It's a setting, not of
post traumatic stress
Because the conflict has not yet subsided.
It's conflict of current/complex trauma,
where the communities and the families
are being constantly exposed to all
these bad things happening.
And it also takes into account
where we know as context,
dependent parenting styles.
So for instance, some
caregivers might become more,
you can say authoritarian
in these settings,
and that's not generally bad.
It's just a response to these
kind of very difficult
settings in which it is, right?
So if something bad is happening
and maybe you just want
to follow your order
as a protective measure, right?
So, we adapted the program
based on these settings in 2015.
And how does it work?
It's a group-based program,
it's delivered in 15 weekly sessions.
So participants meet
groups of approximately 15
to 18 participants meet every
week for two and a half hours.
Here, they meet for two and a half hours.
The sessions are done by
two local facilitators.
And the program tries to
create first awareness
on the emotional,
psychological toll of violence.
In many of these settings,
when we come to talk to the communities,
there's a sort of normalization
of what's happening
and how conflict is affecting.
I think that's very important evolutionary
protective effects.
But it also kind of doesn't allow them
to process how they're affected,
how it affects their emotions,
how it affects also their physical health,
and how it translates into the children.
Then it tries to create
awareness on violence.
- [Enquirer] How did you
choose the size of the group?
- [Moya] So it's based
on the Building Bridges,
so I don't think I have a good answer.
That's the size of the group
of the Building Bridges community program.
- [Enquirer] It seems a big
group plus the children-
- [Moya] So the children don't go.
The children don't go to assessments.
And I'll tell you in a
second why they don't go.
And so at first, again,
it tries to create this awareness
about the emotional tool of conflict,
and also tries to create awareness
on how this affects their
relationship with their children,
and how it's directly affecting children.
And every time we get to new sense,
sort of like parents tell us informally,
in the group discussions
and the focus groups
we conduct before implementing,
that they don't think
that their children are gonna be affected
because maybe they were too young
to understand that their
dad had been murdered
or to understand that there
were like shots around,
like gunshots and
confrontations around them.
But actually we know this is totally off.
Maybe the children are
verbalizing what's happening,
but their behavior and
their brain development
is actually reacting to
these different settings.
So we create awareness on these issues.
And then the program,
what the program tries to
do is to provide some tools
so that caregivers can actually
address some of these issues
so that they can work on
their own mental health.
They can work on the
child-parent relationship
and how this maps up into
better childhood development
and behavior, right?
And in doing so, I think what
the program tries to do is
foster resilience,
try to understand and recognize
that these are communities
that are affected by systematic
and pervasive conflict
that they have within the
families and the communities,
the source of resilience and strength.
We try to create the self
efficacy for the program.
So how do sessions work?
And here I go back to,
or as you saw, comment.
So it's only the caregivers
come to the sessions,
and the idea is that they're not coming in
with their children,
because otherwise this is
gonna take away the focus
from what's happening in
their own emotional world
to what's happening with
the children in sessions.
Oh, and I'm gonna show you
a couple pictures here.
Only the caregivers that are coming
with very young children (indistinct),
but they don't have anybody
to take care of them
while the sessions they're
only allowed to bring them.
And so the sessions
follow similar structure.
At the beginning,
there's a warmup and a
stress reduction practice.
So sensory awareness,
they sometimes they practice
some mindfulness exercises,
sun salutations like in yoga,
then they dig into the main activity.
And this is basically
a reflective practice.
They start understanding
and making this reflection
in terms of how conflict affects them,
how conflict is affecting their children
and their relationship.
And this is all grounded
with arts and crafts
to try to ground the information.
And then at the end,
there's a group discussion
in which the participants
then discuss how they can incorporate this
into their everyday activities.
- [Enquirer] How do you
recruit the participants?
- [Moya] So I'll tell you in two seconds,
but these are families that participate
in the early childhood
centers of the group.
And so the idea is that we're not trying
to put a higher burden on these families,
asking for women to do more
than what they're already doing.
What we try to highlight in
this last group discussion is
how they can incorporate some better
and maybe more appropriately
developmental activities
into their everyday activities, right.
And how they can also start creating these
child-rearing teams,
how they can start involving the fathers,
how they can start involving
other members in the community,
so that they can all contribute
towards early childhood development.
These are the sessions.
Actually, the one on the
left is the first session.
You can see that some participants
are with their children there.
There's a yard and there's an activity
where they start kind of like
throwing the yard between them.
And we're trying to create
some sort of a social structure
and connectedness in these settings.
The one in the right is one of the,
I think it's the 10th session.
You can see there's some arts
and crafts here in the ground,
and they they're discussing
what each of them
actually worked on during the session.
And again,
how they can incorporate this
into their everyday settings.
So that's basically a program.
And as I mentioned, this
is a community led program.
Each group is led by
two local facilitators.
They're facilitators that
have no formal training
in psychosocial programs.
In general, all of them had
some type of social leadership.
They had been leading some type of groups,
but not in a very formal, structured way.
And I think importantly, all
of them are community members.
All of them are mothers.
All of them are exposed to
the same sources of stress
and adversity.
And actually some of them
have been directly affected by violence.
So how we build the local capacities is
through a five week experiential training.
They go through the full program
and it's only by them
going to the full program
that they can then replicate
and lead to implementation.
- [Enquirer] How much formal education
do they typically have?
- So they all, at least at the minimum,
they completed like a bachelor's degree.
And some have some
diplomas in social work,
technical plugs in social work.
I think one of them is a nurse.
And what this does is to try to allows us
to overcome deficit to
mental health service, right?
So in the setting where
we're gonna operate,
setting severely affected by violence,
there's only one psychologist
that has been trained
to provide some type of
mental health service, right.
And what we do,
and I think this is an
important building block
of the program, is a weekly
reflective supervision.
So we have supervisors that
meet with the facilitators.
And the supervision is not focused on
what they need to do next
or the following week,
the supervision instead is focused
on the emotional wellbeing
of these facilitators.
'cause it's harder.
They're already trying to understand
and process their emotions
and how this affects them
and now they have to lead these groups.
So they actually meet for a full day,
every Friday on this
reflective supervision.
And I think this actually allows
to build these local capacities.
- [Enquirer] There are two
questions from the audience.
So one is that if there is
a referral system available
for participants who are exhibiting
severe stress symptomatology.
And the other question is
that if Venezuelan refugees
are in the (voice distorts).
- [Moya] So, two very
important questions, thank you.
So the first one is we do
have a protocol of referrals,
this protocol as we crafted it
out for the IRB (indistinct)
necessary steps to go through
the local health systems.
And this is what we're
required to do by law.
Actually we know that this
referral system actually
has some obstacles, again,
because there's no capacity.
So what we do is we have
apparel system where we do referrals
to different partner organizations
that are working in the field.
So for instance, Heartland
Alliance International,
Save the Children have been
receiving some of the cases
where we see kind of critical case.
And then our supervisors,
and then the team at UCSF
and our lead psychologists
can also come in to address
some of these difficult circumstances.
And the second question,
well, is there refugees?
this program was originally created
for this state's population,
then we kind of start open
the scope for communities
generally affected by conflict.
And we didn't realize that by the third
or cohort of the program
we started receiving Venezuelan refugees
who organically kind of took the step
and started participating.
And the next steps of
what we're preparing,
we're trying to make upfront adaptation
so that we can better address the needs
and the characteristics of
Venezuelan refugees in Colombia,
2 million Venezuelan refugees in Colombia.
That's the program,
then let me tell you about the evaluation.
I'm gonna strike with a
little bit of a context.
Maybe many of you know about this,
but sometimes we lose track of the fact
that Colombia's actually the country
with the highest number of
internally displaced persons
in the world.
So by the end of of last year,
8.2 million internal
displaced persons in Colombia,
let's says 17% of the Columbia population.
This is almost 20% of
all displaced persons.
It's a higher number than what
we have in Syria or the DRC.
Maybe we lose track about this crisis
because it's been a protracted conflict.
So this is the stock of displaced person
that has been legally
recognized since early 1990s.
But this displacement is still happening
as I will show you in a second.
And this displacement
has affected pretty much
every corner of the country.
This map here on the left is showing you
the intensity of displacement
per 100,000 habits
across different
municipalities of the country.
And what you see is just
like the heat map is
totally activated, you
have some spots here.
This is where Bogotá and
the nearby states are,
the Amazon, but then you see
pretty much the whole country
has been affected by displacement.
This is the number of displaced
person since 1997 and 2018.
Displacement is still happening
despite the peace agreement
with the FARC,
with the FARC guerrilla
that was signed in 2016.
Conflict is much active.
This map on the right side,
we took it from Robert
Carl showing you a heat map
of killings of social leaders.
And what you see, it's also
spread around the country.
And we're gonna work on this place here,
which is all also one
of the municipalities
who are affected by conflict, it's Tumaco.
So this is on the border with
Ecuador and the Pacific Coast.
It's the municipality mostly
of African Columbia population,
90% of the Colombian population.
Culturally rich, geographically rich.
It's vibrant, it's
actually a gorgeous place,
but it's also been affected by conflict
because coca leaf crops are grown here.
And then this is just like a
natural pathway for drug trade.
And so different art
groups have been always
getting to Tumaco to get
control of the drug trade.
And as a result, they target
the civilian population
to get this territorial control.
So we're gonna work here.
And this is just to highlight
that this is a setting
of that (indistinct).
These are the homicide rates
in Tumaco and in Colombia,
what you see is very
stable trend in Colombia.
And what you see here
is the trend in Tumaco.
What happened here 2012,
start of peace negotiations
between the Colombian government
and the FARC guerrillas
when we started discussing the possibility
of bringing the program to this place
was around here 2016, 2017.
There was relatively safe conditions,
and we were thinking we were coming
to a post conflict situation.
When we started, you can see
the spike in homicide rates.
So homicide rate is four
times higher than in Columbia.
When you check the intensity
of the displacement,
it's also 943 versus 235, I think.
So it's also high
intensity of displacement
and also a very poor context.
So what you're seeing here
is the map of poverty rates
by block, by census block.
And in general, 45% of
population is considered poor
compared to 20% in Colombia.
And you can see it's
pretty much widespread
across the municipality.
All these are rivers,
where the R groups try to
get control these pathways
to shift the the coca trade out.
And pretty much the only
spot that you don't see here
that are being activated
in terms of poverty,
this is an oil plants,
this is the airport.
This is the collective
commercial tourist beach.
Other than that, poverty
is pretty much widespread.
80% of the population of the
economically active population
are devoted to some informal activity.
So pretty vulnerable
both in terms of conflict
and both in terms of
socioeconomic dimensions, okay.
So (indistinct) were the participants,
these are mothers in general,
primary caregivers of
young children served
by early childhood development centers.
These are centers that serve children
around age three to five
from vulnerable families.
This is part of the From Zero
(speaks foreign language)
From Zero to Forever national policy
that has been evaluated by
many including this paper
by Raquel Bernal and Sara Ramirez in 2019.
I think this is "World Development"
showing positive effects
of the role of the centers
across the country, at least
in terms of the language
and population, I think.
And our experiment is gonna
assign some participants
to a treatment status,
where they have access Semillas de Apego,
and in addition to the regular services
that are provided by those centers.
And then the control group,
these are regular services
provide by the centers, right?
(crosstalk)
(man speaks indistinctly)
- [Enquirer] If a family
less than three years old,
they're out.
- [Moya] If the family has a
child less than three years,
we don't find them because
we're coming into the centers.
That was a decision we had to make
to try to make it feasible for us
to target the appropriate population
and operate in the same, right?
And we only have...
so this is gonna be a cluster
net as we're gonna define
the treatment at the cluster level.
And the clusters are in the centers,
but we only have 18 centers, right?
So at least in terms of statistical power,
it would've made more sense
to randomize individually.
But the fact is that we couldn't.
And the reason is that
they're invisible borders
across neighborhoods, across
street that you cannot cross.
So for instance, take
these two centers here,
they may be two blocks away.
And the community from
this center cannot go
to the community with the center.
When we would come in,
we would have to come in,
maybe go into a street,
get the local leader of that neighborhood.
He would check us in, we would run the,
let's say the surveys.
If we're running to the other center,
we could walk, we couldn't walk.
We had to go up,
different local leader had to pick us up
and then bring us in.
So this actually prevents us from running
the evaluation at the individual level.
And we had to randomize at
the center level, right?
So we stratify, we follow
a two step approach.
First, we assign at the center
level, we take the ECDS,
we have some data on ECD size
and socioeconomic characteristics
across the centers,
and then we randomly assign
the treatment of control status.
So we have nine centers in
treatment that are in control.
And then we take the census
of the population submitted
by the centers.
And we randomly assign participants
over four sequential cohorts.
Our partner in the field
wanted this program to persist.
So we took the census
and we defined, okay,
you're in a treatment center,
then you can participate
in either cohort one,
two, three, or four, right?
And as children were coming in
later, being enrolled later,
we would add them to the
list and then randomize it.
In total, we have 1300
participants per team,
700 assigned to treatment
and 662 to control.
Of course, we were worried
about statistical power
with very few clusters.
This takes ahead as a function
of the intra cluster correlation.
Luckily, at least what we see
from admin data and basing data is
that the Ics are pretty low.
These are pretty much centers that serve
very similar underserved communities.
And at least the power
calculations at the beginning,
we had 80% statistical
power to identify effects
between point 22 and point
26 standard deviations
without any controls for
a baseline (indistinct).
And these are the two
registries over the cover study.
So we're gonna...
We collected baseline four weeks
before the intervention
started in the treatment group,
the program ran for 15 weeks,
we collected a one month follow up then
and we came back and
collected a second follow up
32 weeks, eight months
after the program had ended.
(crosstalk)
- Can I ask a question, sorry about that.
Yeah, just to make it interactive.
And there are some questions
on the chat as well.
So I was wondering, you know, you gave us
what the implementation, what
the program design looks like.
I was just wondering a
little bit about the work
that went into it beforehand,
which is, is the science,
the psychological science
behind this particular
intervention design,
is it well settled or is this
something that, you know,
who was involved in designing the program?
And if somebody then displays
any kind of severe stress
symptoms, you know,
should there be some
pharmacological treatment
as opposed to just non
like we have here?
And there's a related
question from Catherine
that is there a referral system available
when participants exhibit
severe stress symptoms?
- Good, thank you (indistinct) again.
And because I moved here,
I'm not seeing the chat now.
Where?
- [Woman] The chat room.
- Yeah, so you can see me.
I cannot see the chat,
but two very important questions.
Let me start with the second one.
So, yeah, the referral system,
we just spoke about this.
We have a kind of official referral system
to the public health system.
We know that that system doesn't work.
There's only one trained
psychologist in the municipality
that can take in to these cases.
So when we had critical cases,
we referred them to other
partner organizations,
Save the Children and Heartland
Alliance International.
Heartland Alliance
international (indistinct),
some community led
programs in mental health.
And we also had our own
team of psychiatrists
that would come in
and would try to follow up on these cases.
In practice, we only had, I think,
six cases out of 700 and
something participants
that we followed through
these referral protocols.
And then I think taking a step back
and then going into your question,
when we designed this project.
So obviously I'm an economist.
I didn't participate in
the technical design.
This was led by a team of psychologists
at Los Angeles and the team
of psychologists at UCSF.
And so first we...
It took us approximately
six months of focus groups
and interviews with victims of conflict
for displaced populations,
conversations with the
national victims unit,
which is the national institution
that supports all victims initiatives.
We did this in Bogotá mainly.
And we run a pilot to test the feasibility
and acceptability of the curve
to try to see if the way in
which we approach the program
and the context is actually
reasonable and well grounded,
and it's well received by the population.
So it was conducted in 2015
with those support of the
Ministry of Health in Colombia,
and the Inter-American development act.
Then when we move to Tumaco,
it's a totally different setting.
And then we ran again,
maybe like a six month
adaptation into the content
of the program and the way
in which we bring the program
to the community.
That's where we decided to run the program
through the early childhood centers,
because this allows us to find mothers
who have young children and to
come into the neighborhoods.
We were only able to get
into the neighborhoods
because we were getting to the centers.
We weren't able to go
to the houses and so on.
And this is gonna matter also
for the data that we collect.
So I hope that that answers your question.
And maybe the, the other
question I will differ,
on whether there's merits
or some cases merit
from pharmacological interventions.
I think I would defer that
maybe to psychologists
in our team, is that okay?
I think that's beyond my
knowledge and training.
Okay, so as we mentioned, we
have four sequential cohorts.
We follow the same data
collection scheduled
for each of them.
Here you have different dates
in which the data collection happened.
And as you can see here,
we're going to collect the final data
for point three and four in
March, 2020 and June, 2020.
And of course the pandemic came in, right?
And so centers were closed
by the end of February.
Columbia went into international
lockdown March 23rd,
I think.
And so this prevented us
from going back to this.
We did flow a quick phone survey in April,
five to seven weeks
after lockdown started,
I think we were naive.
We thought that maybe by
administering a couple of scales
and questionnaires over the phone,
we could at least save some key dimensions
that we could use for the
full effective innovation.
But as soon as we started
analyzing the data,
we saw that there were just
like high levels of stress,
anxiety, parenting stress,
people were already suffering,
70% or more lost to jobs they were into.
So actually we made an amendment
of the pre-analysis plan,
right as we were running the phone survey,
and the eight month follow up results
are gonna use only the data
for cohort one and two.
And this is important because
we also specified this
in our original pre-analysis plan.
We do not expect or we were not expecting
to see any effects on the first follow up.
And this is pretty much consistent with
or informed by the clinical trials
of the child-parent relationship program,
where we are inspired of.
We were expecting to see the effects
and the seconding follow.
And so of course we lost
half of our sample here of...
You can't imagine the stress
that we also were experiencing.
So we're gonna measure,
we're gonna be focusing
on four main dimensions
based on the theory of
change of the program,
maternal mental health,
child-parent interactions,
child mental health, early childhood.
And we implement and
administer a set of batteries
that have been administered
in other programs
by other researchers or by ourselves
that have been translated
and validated in many cases,
then we know in other cases
have appropriate
psychometric characteristics
for the child-parent interactions.
So one of the best strategies
in the home inventory,
we couldn't do this
because we couldn't go
into the neighborhood.
We had to run all the data
collection in the center.
So most of these are just self reports
from the caregiver who
participated in the program
or the control group.
And for child development,
we have preschool self readiness
assessment at baseline.
And then we go with the
administration of (indistinct),
at the first, at the second follow up,
and Brief Toddler
Socioemotional Assessment.
- [Enquirer] Sorry, did you see this?
Where were the children,
like the small children
were with their parents,
but where were the other ones?
- [Moya] Oh, so they were at the centers.
- [Enquirer] Okay, so
they're being taken care of?
- [Moya] So they were taken
care of and the centers provide,
they dropped them out at around 9:00 AM,
picked them up at 3:00 PM, I think.
So the program was actually implemented
around the schedule the
moms or the caregivers,
usually either after they dropped them out
or before they picked them up, right.
Children receive the...
Their food intake is mainly
driven by the centers,
and so this allowed us to
have the kinda participants
fully focused on the
program instead of like,
figuring out what to
do with with the case.
I can go into this, but
maybe for the sake of time,
I'll just jump and just mention that
at least we got good
psychometric properties.
So we're gonna use all these scales
and bundle into these composite
indices, we do this by GM.
We're gonna standardize
by the controlled group in each wave,
and we're gonna put all signs...
We're gonna switch signs
depending on the scale.
So that positive effects
mean improvements.
And we have-
- I'm sorry to interrupt.
I have a question, given that the focus
of the paper is on mental health
and maternal mental health.
I was wondering if this checklist
doesn't include depression,
which seems to be one of
the primary constructs
predicting parental
investment in children.
And one reason why it's important
to treat depression in women
and depression in particular
among all possible constructs.
- Yeah, that's also a
very good question, Paula.
Thank you, so the symptom check is non ER,
actually provides you
data for nine dimensions
of mental health, anxiety, depression.
- Okay.
- Filled with anxiety,
sensitivity, hostility,
and three other more.
We've been using this one
because what we realized
in different workers.
So at least economists that are starting
to administer these scales, usually focus
on depression or focus on anxiety.
But we are seeing that
in many of our research,
we pick up important domains
when we check into other
dimensions of mental health.
So given the context and
the setting of conflict,
it's not only about depression.
It's also about the sensitivity
of these populations,
what's happening in the setting.
It's also about phobic anxiety,
which is clearly tied up to experiences
of displacement and violence.
So we're able to see this
and the different dimensions.
For now, at least in the composite,
these we're just gonna
bundle everything together.
And I can show you results in a second
when we just take every measure by itself.
Yeah.
- Thank you, yeah.
- Thank you for your question.
And yeah, there's bracket here
that's missing, it's okay.
So the measures work well,
we have good psychometric properties
for the indices when we do
internal consistency measures,
when we do confirm return factor analysis.
So in general, for some
we're connect borderline,
and so we show that at least
our results are robust.
If we include, we take
these measures, okay.
And some descriptives,
average, eight participants,
29 years old, 87% of them are the mothers.
We have some grandmothers,
we had three or four fathers actually,
who decided to came up and participated.
We know from their anecdotes
that were actually
buried by the community.
This is very patriarchal,
strong gender norms.
And so the community
we're actually making fun
of them when they decided to
participate in women's groups.
Child age was two and a half years
at the beginning of
the program in general.
Most of the children connected,
sure that we measured,
is actually the second children,
82% of them direct victims of violence
exposed to an average 2.3,
different violent events.
57% of them had been
displaced at some point,
and just let me show you this here.
This is the distribution of
the direct violent events,
and on the right side,
you see the maternal mental health index,
you can see like a very small left in pale
that show the highlights of this
sensitivity to conflict here.
And also very poor.
Sorry, this is not...
So here, we're comparing the
asset index for the community
in Tumaco with participants of Tumaco,
with the asset index
for the nationally
representative population
that is collected by the data of the ELCA.
(indistinct) That we were
administering in the surveys.
And you can see just the
distribution in Tumaco,
just like all the way to the left.
So we're targeting the
population in one chart.
Okay.
And at least on baseline,
what we see is that connected dimensions
that motivated this program,
the effect of violence
on maternal mental health
and the effect of maternal mental health
on all these other dimensions,
they show up at these
basic correlations at base.
So we see that higher levels of violence
in baseline are associated with
worse maternal mental health,
worse child-parent relationships,
worse early child mental health.
What we see is that when there's
a kind of positive
caregiver's mental health,
this is actually associated
with better outcomes
in the child-parent relationships,
and what's happening with the child.
So at least with descriptives,
we see that the fear of
changes is important.
So again, remember these were 15 sessions
and that we ran the
program in four cohorts
based on the insights
of the partners at UCSF.
Pre basically decided that
when somebody participates
in at least six sessions,
they kind of graduate from program.
This has to be the first six sessions.
And so you can see that
at the beginning goes 40%
of those that were invited
ended up participating.
And this setting has to do with the way
in which we engage in communities.
At the beginning it was me,
talking to communities
about what we wanted to run.
Then we kind of realized it's better
if actually the local
facilitators do this process.
And then you can see
this greater engagement.
An average that we have participation was
of 11 sessions conditional
of participating
at least one session.
So when we see connect
the survival analysis,
what happens is if they go to
the first or second sessions,
they pretty much stay.
It was just part of beginning
to try to get some people to participate.
And our experiment works well,
we have journal validity,
balance on center characteristics,
balance on individual
hazard characteristics.
We don't find that any of
the basic characteristic
explaining participation in the program.
And we did, I think I can say this,
I think a good job in terms
of reducing attrition,
only 4% and 10%,
and not different between the treatments.
I think this is a testament
of the survey team (indistinct)
because we did I think a good job
in trying to not lose
track of the populations,
even though they were migrating,
even though some of them
were being displaced
as the program was happening.
So, how much time do we have?
It's 3:30?
- [Woman] No, 3:45.
- [Moya] So, we're gonna
follow two empirical strategy.
The first one exploits
the random assignment
to treatment or control arms
again, by this center level.
So we're gonna run lag
dependent variable models.
We're gonna run one of the composite
and disease for each
of the dimensions here
on the treatment status, on the
composite index at baseline,
we're gonna control for baseline family
and individual characteristics.
We're gonna control for
the cohort, fix effects,
our baseline controls are demeaned
and interacted with the treatments.
And then we're gonna
adjuster cluster errors
for the small number of clusters,
following Pustejovsky and Tipton.
We also do some estimations
with a wild boost trip,
and things are pretty consistent.
We're gonna adjust for
multiple hypothesis testing
using the (indistinct).
And then we're also as a robustness tech,
we're gonna exploit an
alternative social variation,
and this is the variation
within treatment.
So again, remember that
within the treatment centers,
we assign randomly participants
to four sequential cohorts.
And then it turns out that
this created this phase
and design that we can actually exploit.
So at the moment, for
instance, that the cohort one
was participating in the first follow up.
Cohort two was participating in baseline.
So we can use this to test also
the first follow up results.
And we can use this to test
for those second follow up results,
unless we thought about this,
when we were adjusting P analysis plan
based on the interruptions
from the pandemic,
because it allows us to move away
from the cluster assignment.
So it might have a little bit more power.
And then let me show you the results
on the four main dimensions on the print.
So first in terms of
maternal mental health,
and I think it's expected,
we don't see much in the first follow up.
So in these tables, I'm showing
you lack for transparency,
what happens when we only control
for the lack of an invariable?
What happens when we include
poorly fixed effects?
What happens when we include controls,
and what happens with the
treatment on the treated
when we instrument by
the random assignment.
And we can see in the first follow up,
it's just not only not as
statistically significant
but pretty much these
are almost zeros, right?
And then what happens at
the eight month follow up,
we start picking up these sizeable
and statistically significant effects.
Notice here that we're
losing half of the sack.
And this is pretty much
because of the pandemic,
because we weren't able to go back
and follow up on these populations
for chords three and four,
because of the lockdown.
So even though we have
spotter sample size,
and this translates into
larger standard errors,
we still see effects of
point 15 standard deviations
in the maternal mental health dimension,
and we see when we
actually do the treatment
this is actually 27 standard deviations.
What happens with the
child-parent relationships?
We didn't expect this,
but we are picking up
statistically significant effects.
At the first follow up
of 0.14 standard deviations on the ITT
point 227 deviations on the
treatment on the treated.
What happens at the eight month follow up?
Effects are actually larger,
even almost twice as large,
and much more precise.
Even though, again, here
we're losing precision
because of the smaller sample size.
So at the eight-month follow up
on the effects on the
child-parent relationship scale
(indistinct) point 23 standard
deviations on the ITT.
Point 42 standard
deviations on the treatment
on the treated.
And please interrupt if
you want me to stop by
some of these responses.
And then when you think
about child dimensions,
so one is the child mental health.
This is measured by the child
trauma symptom checklist Y.
Not any effects here
at the first follow up,
when we actually think there's...
Oh, in the first follow
up we don't see much
in terms of mental health,
early child development,
but then again, you can notice
at the eight month follow up
sizeable and statistically
significant effects
in child mental health,
and also in the early child
development domain, right?
So point 17 and point
21 effects of the intent
to treat early child development domains.
And then just as to test what's happening,
we do this within treatment strategy.
And what we find here,
the structure of these
tables is different.
The first two columns are
showing first follow ups.
The first follow up,
the second two columns
are showing the eight month follow ups
And what you can see here,
is pretty much the same
picture as we were getting...
And the lag dependent variable model,
not much in terms of the effects
that the first follow up,
but then these sizeable
effects at the second part.
- [Enquirer] Do you know, this
might be an unfair question,
do you know the standard deviation
of the control group in these variables?
- [Moya] So we are standardizing
by wave and the control group.
So in each...
- [Enquirer] It's one.
- It's what?
- [Enquirer] These impacts,
I mean, I know a bit,
the stuff of the ECD,
they're large, they're huge.
- [Moya] They're large.
But I'm gonna show you that
at least in ECD they're large,
but here they're driven
by the self-reported
scale of the moms.
We don't see much of the (indistinct).
So we see pretty much a no
effect with a lot of dispersion.
When we dig into the self
dimensions of the (indistinct),
we're seeing some things
in terms of socioemotional
and executive functions,
but then the next step
is what we're discussing
in terms trying to
combine thought measures
from different scales.
And then we do this
across the sub dimensions.
So maybe Paula was asking this before,
let me show you just that
we split up the composite
and this is across the
different sub dimensions,
this is the effect on the likelihood
of being above the risk thresholds?
And here far enough for
institute so you can see
depression, anxiety.
Anxiety sensitivity is still
the measure locus for control.
So a negative effect here
is a positive effect,
it reduces the likelihood
of being at risk.
And so you can see at least
in general connect these,
all the other effects
being on the right side.
But as I was mentioning, (indistinct),
no effect, super imposed.
And then let me point to
two additional effects
in the 10 minutes that we have.
So one week
we tried to do some
analysis of heterogeneity.
So at first we had specified
that we were gonna use
this causal forest protocols.
We don't find any discernible patterns,
and basically that's probably
because of statistical power.
So these methods require
very large samples,
we don't have it.
And actually when we run
this, the effects are
pretty imprecise and inconsistent.
It actually depended a lot
on the seeds that choose.
But then, we follow kind
of a more standard method
where we split the sample across key
characteristics at baseline,
and specifically displacement,
based on mental health and
socioeconomic vulnerability.
And these are what we're finding.
So, what is in terms of
the differential effects
on whether the person
was displaced or not,
we don't see much.
We don't see that many differences,
and actually to see these are the P values
for the differences, maybe
one, a little bit here,
but they're too precise.
When we see a car according
to maternal mental health
below the median
that's where we start
picking up some heterogene.
So we can see that at
the eight month funnel,
the effects are larger for those
that had higher levels of
maternal mental health problems.
Those that work at risk at basic,
that's when we start seeing
like a more positive and stronger effects.
And you can see that
despite the small sample,
these differences in
the price statistic is-
(crosstalk)
- [Enquirer] This is how
the productive (indistinct).
- [Moya] Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, and so I'm not
reporting with the slide,
I need to check.
So at first we were, I
need to check here why
we're reporting the P
value not the Q value.
And then when we check
also across vulnerability,
we're seeing that it seems
that the effects are being positive
for those that are not extremely poor.
So within a very poor environment,
at least those that are below the median,
that acid index that I showed you,
there are the ones that are...
So the ones that not below
that asset median index,
they're the ones where we start
picking up some effects again,
at least in mental health,
that's where it's a sizeable effect.
So this kinda takes us a little bit,
points into a direction sort
of a Maslow hierarchy of needs.
So maybe interesting dimensions
when we think about future programs,
about whether this has to be run
within the early child
development centers,
where they at least get some
type of social services,
and this is gonna be important.
And we were speaking about this earlier,
in terms of how do we, for instance,
target this program to
Venezuelan refugees.
So 2 million refugees that
are in dire circumstances,
many of them are not being able
to access conditional
test transfers or centers.
So how does it work
when you don't have at least
the food to feed your kids,
do you have like the space
for this emotional processing growth?
- [Woman] Do you think they would be going
to city (indistinct) Tumaco, I mean,
probably.
- [Moya] No, no, no.
- [Woman] They are?
- [Moya] So they're
some of them are getting to Tumaco
because it's in the border with Ecuador.
So some of them as they
migrate across the country,
they start selecting the places
where they're gonna live in.
The majority come to big cities,
but you start seeing
that across rural areas,
they're also getting their...
It's okay.
And the second result
that I wanted to highlight
is this kind of deep effect
of the COVID pandemic.
So this is code three and four,
this was the evolution and baseline.
First follow up, we're
expecting something like this,
based on what was happening
points one or two.
We weren't able to measure this,
we deployed the phone survey.
And what you see is
this kind of very strong
and sizeable increase in at
risk symptoms of anxiety.
We see four weeks into a pandemic,
an increase in 14 percentage points
and at risk symptoms of anxiety,
5% for...
Five percentage points for depression,
percentage points for parent distress.
I think so this was when lockdown was...
We had just gone into lockdown,
but then nine months later,
11 months later, we deployed
a second survey in November,
and we see still very
kind of accessible effects
for anxiety, depression,
stress, some preliminary results
that I don't wanna stress that much.
We do see that at the November,
2020 follow up phone survey,
it seems that the
treatment helped mitigating
some of these effects.
So, the paper analyzing the effects
on the first follow
was published last year
at the Lancet Global Health.
So, five minutes left,
let me just wrap up.
Again, I think what we
try to innovate here
is to address and I think it's motivated
by the effects of conflict
and maternal mental health
and how actually this
is important by itself,
but also important because it affects
the capacity of these caregivers
to provide these stimulating
and developmentally appropriate
settings for the children.
And I think the innovation
also is implementing this
through the community.
- [Enquirer] Yeah, sorry,
before you recruit,
This is very interesting.
One thing that was perplexed is,
why did you decide to go with the CDIs?
And what I remind is that, for instance,
if you were to use, I don't
know how to map at all.
So I might be not feasible there,
but if you go to the
family, the family is the...
And you could do that
organization across families,
because already they
have meetings in groups.
It seemed to be a very natural environment
where you try to do that
kind implementation.
The families mother are
typically local women,
you know, implemented in that context,
they do get much larger
sample size, probably.
And it's true that the
family, as for zero to two,
but lots of these ladies
compare in any care.
First of all, it's a good
time to do the intervention.
And they might have older children
given that your focus is on the mothers.
So, you know, maybe there
are no families (indistinct).
- [Moya] So to be honest,
I'm not sure if they
have (voice distorts).
I never heard about the program operating
as we were planning this intervention.
So the focus CDIs was basically
because we partnered up
with an organization in the
field called Genesis Foundation,
which was sort operator for CIF
through the early childhood centers.
And so they allowed occasional comment
and you can run the program here.
But I think your comment
is very, very important
as we're now trying to
figure out how to scale.
- [Enquirer] You should
have chat with the...
because family is (voice distorts).
So to me seems the more...
Because you already have groups
like it's actually smaller the 15,
that was why I asked the
question at the beginning.
Yeah, it's like nine or 10.
and the children go there
'cause they're really small.
(voice distorts)
- So that's very good comment, thank you.
And I think it helps us on...
And just to wrap up, maybe,
so again, I discussed this at length,
this implementation in the
context of ongoing conflict
of a complex current trauma.
And I think in general,
the results speak both to the need.
We need to think hard
about these programs.
We need to bring them in,
we need to evaluate them,
but also that it's not only
needed, but also feasible.
And when we think about cost effectiveness
or the scalability, cost
per participant was 435.
The nearest program for the (indistinct).
they were running a
program called Me Familia.
They were starting to design
it before the pandemic.
The program for participant was $600.
- [Enquirer] This is per year?
- [Moya] Per participant per year.
And then the near CBT,
just not comparable,
but the near CBT program is $6,000, right?
So we can do this and
we can do this properly.
I think a reasonable cost, right?
And so right now we're working
on what we call at-scale pilot,
we're handing in the operation
to an external partner,
actually Cardinal Alliance,
which was, if you remember
the organization in Tumaco
that provided some
mental health turnovers,
we're moving towards five municipalities
in the Caribbean Coast
and the Pacific region,
different populations
in the Caribbean Coast
(indistinct) which have high
influx of Venezuelan refugees.
So we're already starting to
adapt the implementation there.
And there's an ongoing
conversation to enhance the model
with some play-based activities.
And again, I mentioned at the beginning,
we're trying to address
the different restriction,
but of course this doesn't
mean that the restrictions
that other programs are trying
to address are not there.
So how can we compliment these strategies?
And we're working with Sesame
Workshop to try to compliment,
maybe have some activities
for the children
and for this part we're gonna be using
an implementation science
evaluation framework.
So mostly focusing on the processes
and not on the impacts.
We're gonna do a pre-post follow up
but not a proper impact in an issue.
And I think that's it.
I think right on time, maybe
I went for one more minute.
And so thank you again for the time
and for the opportunity to
present here, your comments.
And I don't know if there's
something in the chat.
- No, there are no more
questions in the chat.
So I dunno if the audience in Zoom
would like to ask some questions.
(crosstalk)
- Somebody wants to follow up, hold on.
- Teresa or Andrés can I ask a question?
- Yes, go, of course.
- So I saw in at the beginning of the talk
and at the end of the talk as well
that 50% of your sample were IDPs.
So I assume that everyone
else was more or less
considered to be part
of the host community.
So I guess out of curiosity,
I wanted to ask you if
you observed differences
in the type of trauma and violence
that these two populations
have experienced.
And if you do observe
differences whether...
I would be surprised
that there are no heterogeneous
effect along that dimension.
And I think it would be an important point
for the paper to say,
regardless of the type
of exposure to violence
that these populations experience,
which to me could be
either betrayal trauma
in the form of IPD or, you
know, exposure to conflict.
The fact that the intervention works
regardless of the type of trauma
that these women are exposed to,
could be an interesting angle
to emphasize in this data.
- Okay, yeah, thank you.
I think that's a great comment.
So one, my perception is
that we're not picking up.
So my intuition was that
we were gonna be picking up
heterogene across the IDP dimension.
We don't, but I think
maybe there's a chance
that this is just basically
'cause of lack of sample power, right?
So in general you needn't
collect 16 times the,
like a larger sample to be
picking up some heterogene
in some of these dimensions.
And that's, I think where
your comment (indistinct)
on adjusting for multiply
purpose testing comes in neatly.
So that's part of the
story in the second part.
We haven't tested or analyzed the data
in this dimension that you mentioned
in terms of differences
and exposure to violence
or trauma among displaced
and non displaced persons.
These are general communities,
some of them have been displaced
within their own municipality
from different neighborhoods,
as different R groups
get to a neighborhood,
the community has to move away.
They're pretty much
integrated in the communities.
We don't have displaced camps in Columbia.
The displaced arrive
and they're pretty much the same, culture,
everything is the same.
And they settle in
outskirts of the cities,
in Tumaco it's pretty much
the same neighborhood.
So at least when you talk to people,
you don't see any kind
of main differences.
But we can think about analyzing the data
also in the way that you proposed,
And I think your comment in terms of like,
if this works for these two
kind of like dimensions,
that's a good point to emphasize,
thank you so much for that comment.
- So if you join me thanking
Andrés for the presentation
and any extra question, you
can send an email Monday.
So thank you very much, everybody.
- Thank you so much.
(all clapping)